hi guys it's bradley from sum sub first
of all i just want to thank everyone
that voted
in our little questionnaire that we did
this is going to be one of those topics
that you voted for so i really hope you
enjoy
today i'm going to talking about the
term that was coined by a small article
about the work of search algorithms and
actually ended
up as an important concept of political
life you've probably heard this term
it's called filter bubbles now this is
not coined by engineers or programmers
but rather
politicians and journalists so what is a
filter bubble well
let me explain
[Music]
for too many of us it's become safer to
retreat into our own bubbles
whether in our neighborhoods or on
college campuses
or places of worship or especially
our social media feeds these are the
words from barack obama's farewell
speech now the former us president put
the
information bubble on par with some of
the main threats to democracy namely
international terrorism
and racial inequality impressive well in
fact by the end of 2016
filter bubbles become one of the most
discussed concepts on the web
although to understand this concept we
really need to go back another six years
[Music]
in the spring of 2011 eli parisson made
a real splash with his book
the filter bubble what the internet is
hiding from you as a young political
scientist from massachusetts
he claimed the algorithms of search
engines and social networks form a
distorted picture
of the world around you what you are
currently seeing on the computer screen
is selected personally for you google
and facebook analyze dozens of different
factors to show
what will be relevant for you
individually and everything is taken
into account
geolocation the model of your computer
or smartphone your search history for
instance
and you won't even notice how different
your google is
from your neighbors google there are 57
signals
that google looks at everything from
what kind of computer you're on
to what kind of browser you're using to
where you're located
that it uses to personally tailor your
query results
think about it for a second there is no
standard google anymore
now personal search results and filters
form a unique
closed universe around you which we call
the bubble
you find yourself in a personalized
matrix and search engines decide
what you'll effectively see in it
algorithms are always striving to keep
you online
as long as possible and to do this they
raise the priority of certain
information that they think
you should like therefore instead of you
getting a balanced flow of information
you get a menu of solid deserts and
pleasures
now if they don't think a piece of news
will be liked by you well it's promptly
taken away and removed and the more time
you spend online the more
comfortable your own personal
information bubble will become
now we see and hear only what we want to
see in here and that's effectively a
vicious cycle right
now this discovery became a real
sensation and paris's ted talk was
watched by more than five million people
the book in fact became a bestseller but
is this information bubble so
indisputable let's now take a break from
google and facebook and instead we'll
talk about tv shows
you've probably watched stranger things
on netflix i mean do you remember what
the cover of the series looked like
was it like this is it like this or
maybe this
or this what about that one or maybe
this one
i often saw the fourth variant but i've
got no idea which one you saw
the fact is that for that series for the
first time ever a cover was used that
was automatically generated to be
similar
to the kind of tv shows and films that
you
enjoyed before now personal
recommendation algorithms have basically
created netflix
it started as a business for renting
dvds with
internet-based orders but the network
bandwidth wasn't really enough for video
instead it was just about enough for
pictures of the dvd covers you might
have
chosen a dvd from the website and then
the courier would have brought it to
your house go to netflix.com
make a list of the movies you want to
see and in about one business day
you'll get three dvds in ordinary rental
shops there are always these consultants
who helped you to choose films on the
netflix website
their role was played by personalized
suggestions
for each user the movie catalog looked
different now
also movies were offered taking into
account previous orders and search
history
now as the years went on these
algorithms became more and more
complicated and today
netflix has detailed statistics on all
of your actions i'm talking about how
long you took to choose a movie which
movies you prefer
how many times you paused during the
movie and whether or not you waited for
that secret clip at the end after the
credits but ultimately also
what you watched next and these
statistics became the basis
for the cover personalization service so
now when you're discussing your favorite
tv series
with your friends ask them what kind of
cover they see
in their information bubble
[Music]
so with netflix everything's pretty
simple right i mean you won't be able to
watch anything without a subscription
and the subscription via a bank card
unambiguously links the profile on the
service with
the real you but how are things
personalized on google
how much of what i google is used to
personalize my bubble take a look i'm
going to first of all log into my google
account
i'll conduct a search on google just
regular old google i'll then switch to
incognito mode and i'll conduct the same
search i'll then take order the
anonymous brave browser
and i'll check how many trackers are
following my every move we'll take turns
looking for
brexit lockdown emigration to the uk
the tokyo olympics and let's say the
covet 19 vaccine because this is very
current
now through brave we can actually open
up the statistics of blocked trackers
most likely the order of the low lines
in the results the order of hints and
contextual advertising
it will all differ but this is fine if
the differences are really noticeable
then
we'll pay more attention to them
[Music]
[Music]
well there are differences here but they
don't seem too critical the order of the
results at the bottom of the page is
slightly different
now this may seem insignificant but any
internet marketer will tell you how
critical
a shift of even one position up or down
can be for the number of clicks
yes the difference is measured by
percentages but for popular queries
those percentages
turn into hundreds of thousands of views
and clicks
of course the contextual advertising may
also differ
and the display of it is influenced by
how these search engines see me with the
same
request advertising is most likely to be
different for men and women
depending on things like age and
geolocation so what's happening is it
seems as though they have some sort
they're trying to predict what we want
right so they look at all their searches
and they're like huh for some reason
a bunch of will search on obama and then
iran and so in general we might just
assume that because a lot of people do
that sequence of searches that there's
some
link between those and then they link
them but after all eli paris has
provided much more
vivid examples here now when he asked
his friends to search for information
about egypt
some of them came across tour
information but some
news about the riots in the centre of
cairo here's my friend
scott's screenshot and here's my friend
daniel's screenshot
when you put them side by side you don't
even have to read the links to see how
different
these two pages are now why didn't i
manage to receive the same kind of
contrasting result well first of all
how do they manage to deceive google
incognito mode just
doesn't save your search history when
using google you'll always keep
personality
even with these trackers blocked i
didn't erase my digital fingerprints
which i talked about in the last video
by the way
but look are you surprised here we
wouldn't be alone 65
of americans are unaware of the
vulnerability of private browsing
so number two ten years have passed
since the publication of the book
and the algorithms have changed and
they've ultimately become more subtle
and more complex and number three is the
concept of the filter bubble itself
so indisputable is there a bubble at all
well the metaphor of the information
bubble turned out to be extremely clear
and
understandable thanks to this it was so
loved by politicians and journalists
now in the fall of 2016 in the light of
the results of the american presidential
election
you'd really have to live under a rock
not to remember this theory in all its
glory
filter bubbles have often been ascribed
to one of the tools of donald trump's
victory according to a common theory
supporters of the democratic party
simply did not see those who are going
to vote for the eccentric billionaire
the republicans publications ultimately
remained outside of that
democratic information bubble do you
remember the first reaction to the
election results on social media
the essence of most of the posts were
described by the phrase
neither i nor any of my friends voted
for trump how could this be
huffington post calling it fright night
down to the wire
over at buzzfeed they're talking about
people losing their damn minds over how
close this race is
this is often cited as proof of the
filter bubble theory
it's obvious that search engines and
your facebook news feed have formed a
one-sided picture of the world right
or wrong well no in fact this is a
psychological mistake
and it's connected with the fact that we
ourselves are responsible for the
information picture that is
formed around us i'd like to welcome to
the stage phenomenon known as the echo
chamber
[Music]
imagine that on your friends list you
have an equal number of republicans and
democrats
they behave as they usually would on any
social network they're reposting
political propaganda they're liking
other people's posts and so on
how would you behave i mean you'd have
to admit that you'd give
more attention to those that positively
evaluate material that you sympathize
with
you'd probably even go as far as
unfriending or blocking those who annoy
you with their
unsympathetic statuses or political
viewpoints now most users would behave
in the same way
but by the same token you are unlikely
to repost a meticulous journalistic
investigation about the past of your
candidate
but you would spread a meme of him in
support of him right
of course it's more pleasant for us to
share similar thoughts and not pay
attention to our opponents
because of that your opponents may
unfriend you or pay less attention to
your statuses
and if so you will eventually find
yourself in a situation called the echo
chamber
where specific ideas and views are
reinforced over and over again by
repetitions within a closed system think
of it kind of like a book club or a
political party
you know that there are other opinions
outside of the room but they're really
drowned out
by your supporters and your sympathizers
therefore in order not to find yourself
in such a voluntary
isolation i recommend that you change
your approach to commenting and
distributing information
evaluate well-prepared materials
positively even if the position of their
author does not coincide with yours at
all
don't be afraid to repost unpleasant
analytics about your party
the main criterion should be the quality
of information
yeah well you know that's just like uh
your opinion man the authors of the
article exposure to ideologically
diverse news and opinion on facebook
came to similar conclusions the main
driving force of the echo chamber
hypothesis
is the actions of the users with whom we
contact which
stories we click on and not the choices
that the news feed algorithm makes on
our behalf in recent years a lot of
studies have appeared on the web that
cast
doubt on the real danger of personalized
delivery
also in the decade that has passed since
the publication of that book
search engines have become much more
complex now upon googling bp
situations when republicans would get
ordinary news while democrats would get
news regarding oil spills
is certainly a thing of the past
recently i came across an article by the
creators of the independent search
engine duckduckgo which describes an
experiment exploring the bubble
already in existence now 87 volunteers
from different states simultaneously
entered the same queries into google
most of them received different search
results even while in
incognito mode the results in the news
and video tabs were
noticeably different now this was
probably either due to subtle
personalization
or the search engine gave priority for
example to local
news i don't know for sure now therefore
i'm going to try and repeat this
experiment with my friends
of course those of whom weren't too
offended by my latest endeavors in
social engineering
so i sent a message to my friends asking
them to go to google at exactly five
o'clock and search for three things
lockdown immigration to the uk the cover
19 vaccine
of course they'd have to send me the
search results with screenshots
now here's what we got so first off i
need to contact five different people
now i'm not going to use people from my
classic group of friends as i may be
living in an information bubble myself
so i'm going to choose people that are
very different to one another and people
that ultimately don't know
each other this guy first up his name's
zach
so he was one of my old school friends
he recently got engaged and
he's currently working as an architect
in london
next up is tom so i met tom when i was
traveling in saint petersburg we worked
in the same company together as english
teachers next up is my mate joe's he's
the oldest of old when it comes to
friends he actually graduated as
a professional animator so he's
currently working as a video game
designer which is quite cool
you can see stuff on youtube actually
right leave a link i'm not sure
next this is my lovely mother so she's a
piano teacher
she likes drinking sort of exotic teas
she has a camper van
things like that and she lives in a
little cottage in the south of england
so
good for our experiment my cousin harry
he basically lives in a large sort of
three-bedroom detached house that he
just bought i think in the sort of
southwest of england
he is currently training to be a dental
nurse which is pretty cool
and lastly i actually need to go to
whatsapp to message my mate alex so
alex is basically my scholar of a mate
who's currently studying for his phd at
lse
basically he's the sort of guy that
would get into a debate with you
over twitter about something to do with
politics
i ultimately think this is a really good
mix of people so hopefully we should be
able to observe a number of different
information bubbles here right
interesting so the results are in
uh let's first take a look at when
people searched for covid 19 or the
cobin 19 pandemic
we'll start with my mum the first top
story it's unsurprising it's very
pessimistic
over 19 uk top six million coronavirus
cases
it's 31 808 new infections recorded so
you know this fits in with my mom's
character she's very pessimistic she
wants to always know
what you know is going on that's bad or
worrying or something
uh right let's move on to
tom interesting so tom's actually got
information that's
really sort of socioeconomic you've got
here
brazil top justice orders bolsonaro
investigated for fraud claims
interesting and then you've also got
some financial charts here that's quite
interesting pandemic has boosted firm
investments
it's really different to my mom's one
actually and then
let's compare this with alex's one uh
right
interesting so alex has got a lot of
news about the vaccine so look at this
young people told to get jabbed or miss
out on the good times
there's actually two articles in that
topic welsh leader rules out threatening
young people to get cover jabs so
you know maybe alex is more worried
about not getting vaccine or getting the
vaccine i'm not too sure
that's really interesting they are
completely different
let's take a look at tom's result
okay so we've got a link expectedly to
golf.uk
and there are also some questions here
sort of can i immigrate to the uk how do
i permanently move to the uk things like
that
and also an additional result uh on the
side modern immigration to the united
kingdom
okay let's move on to my mom's result
now that's exactly the same
so that hasn't been changed at all okay
let's move again
and now this is harry my cousin's
results and as you can see even on his
mobile it's exactly the same however he
does have one additional result
which is browse visas and immigration
applied to visit work study
settle or seek asylum in the uk
interesting so i wonder why he got that
result
but anyway this sort of makes sense
because these people are all
uk citizens i mean i imagine if i had a
friend that was safe from spain
his results would be slightly different
okay last but not least we've got
lockdown
now you can see here in joe's result
we've got a couple of top stories
further covered lockdowns in the uk are
now unlikely lockdown is unlikely to be
needed again
no more lockdowns so very positive news
from joe's side
if we go on to my mum's result you can
see that it's actually talking fairly
pessimistically about australia's
new lockdown melbourne goes into another
lockdown as sydney hits new peak of
infections you can see because my mum's
you know i suppose rather pessimistic
she's getting different results
really interesting
in 2020 last year every inhabitants of
the earth was generating around 1.7
megabytes of information per second
google processes more than 40 000
requests per second and the size of
facebook
well that increases by four petabytes
each day
it's not just a lot it's mind-boggling
and
we are not able to filter evaluate
understand even a
small fraction of this information
therefore i really don't think we could
do without
search algorithms but then another
difficult question arises
if the quality of pages or articles is
evaluated based on our behavior
if the position of the search depends on
how many people have read
agreed or shared a certain publication
then who is actually to blame for the
polarization of opinions
if we consciously express our position
with likes and reposts
well who's really responsible for this
appearance of the echo chamber is it
robots or is it people is it us now this
video is actually quite a good example
my statement that politicians often
distort or substitute the concept of the
filter bubble
is unlikely to appeal to republican
supporters but
try to treat my research objectively
without political overtones
after all you're probably wondering in
his farewell speech did barack obama
really make a mistake about this
phenomenon
well anyway vote on that with likes and
reposts tell us in the comments whether
you're struggling to come to terms with
this
whether this is actually something you
sort of expected
my name is bradley and this is some sub
channel on how to survive in the online
jungle so stay tuned
and we'll be answering more than just
one difficult question in the future
see you soon
[Music]
you